so
and then this will probably
uh
[Music]
is
is
um
oh
[Music]
and i think the dna
with a tiny voltage is
[Music]
it is
too much
145
oh
yes
nothing
so
um
um
so
ready
uh
you
mm-hmm
so yeah
okay
i should say
is
everything
okay
um um
god
thank you
wow
do you need anything nope you're not
going to wear a mic aren't you
okay
so
two-minute warning for the press
briefing two-minute warning
where's my coffee
um
hi everyone
we have a few updates for you all at the
top this morning
first today the president is signing
three executive orders
to rebuild and strengthen our
immigration system
these actions are centered on the basic
premise that our country is safer
stronger and more prosperous with a fair
safe
and orderly immigration system today's
actions do a number of things
the first executive order creates a task
force
chaired by the secretary of homeland
security to reunify family families
which will work across government to
find parents and children separated by
the prior administration
the second executive order develops a
strategy to address the root causes of
my
of migration across our borders and
creates a humane
asylum system including directing dhs to
take steps to end
the migrant protection protocols program
which had led to a humanitarian crisis
in northern mexico
and the third executive order promotes
immigrant into integration and inclusion
and ensures that our legal immigration
system operates fairly and efficiently
by instructing agencies to review the
public charge rule
and related policies as many of you
also may have been on the briefing call
that we had a little bit earlier today
but for those of you who are not
uh we've announced or jeff science
announced our our covid coordinator i
should say
that starting on february 11th the
federal government will deliver to
select
pharmacies across the country additional
vaccine
that's coming online next week this will
provide more sites for people to get
vaccinated in their communities
and is an important component to
delivering vaccines equitably
more than 90 of americans live within
five
miles of a pharmacy and i don't know
about you my mother-in-law my family
calls me all the time figuring out how
they can call the cvs and find out when
they can get their
vaccine uh this is a limited launch of
the program but supply will ultimately
go up to 40 000 pharmacies nationwide
second we continue to work to ensure
states tribes and territories have the
resources they need to turn
vaccines into vaccinations president
biden has already
directed fema to fully reimburse states
for the cost of national guard personnel
and other emergency costs and today we
go further by fully reimbursing states
for the eligible services they provided
back to the beginning of the pandemic
in january of 2020 that means that
states will be fully repaid for things
like
mass gloves mobilization of the national
guard
and they can use the additional
resources for vaccination efforts and
emergency
supplies moving forward this
reimbursement effort is estimated
to total three to five billion dollars
and is only a share of the resources
that states need to fight
this pandemic which as we've talked
about a bit in here before includes
testing genomic sequencing and mass
vaccination centers
last we announced that we would increase
weekly vaccine allocation to the states
for the next three weeks
by an additional five percent following
last week's 16 percent increase
so we've increased supply by more than
20 percent since the president took
office just about two weeks ago
these actions speak to the daily work we
are doing to mount the coordinated
federal pandemic response americans need
and reserve
and and deserve i should say as you also
know
last night the president had a meeting
with 10 republican senators
he's meeting right now with the senate
democratic caucus over
video to further discuss the american
rescue plan and we'll have a readout on
that
later this afternoon that we will send
out um
he last night during the meeting he
welcomed the opportunity to have a
constructive exchange
of ideas over how we can improve the
american rescue plan
he pledged that he would bring people
together when he ran for president
and last night was an example of doing
exactly
that a new poll yesterday by yahoo and
yougov
showed that this plan has already
garnered bipartisan support among the
american people
um he also reiterated or we
he we would like to rate it i should say
the urgency of acting quickly on the
package
you all asked yesterday about the cbo
reports a new analysis that came out by
the cbo
that without action in that report
showed also that without action our
economy won't reach
pre-pandemic levels until 2025. that's
too long
so our goal uh with moving this package
forward
is making it faster i have a couple of
additional
readouts or follow-ups i should say from
some
questions that have been asked in here
over the last several days
somebody asked the earlier i think it
was last week about puerto rico
today there's an update i have the
administration is releasing 1.3 billion
dollars in aid allocated by congress
support to puerto rico that can be
deployed to protect against future
climate
disasters in partnership with the puerto
rico department of housing the
administration is also working to remove
onerous restrictions put in place by the
last administration
on nearly five billion dollars in
additional
funds someone also asked yesterday about
how president biden
keeps in touch there's a number of ways
but he
receives correspondence letters in his
briefing book every night as past
presidents have done
he also regularly connects with
americans on the phone we've put out
some videos of that and we'll continue
to do that
moving forward and as you also know he
attends
his routine of attending typical routine
i should say of attending public mass
every weekend which is something he did
as president-elect and something he will
do clearly respecting covet protocols
moving forward there was also a question
sorry a couple follow-ups here about
um uh the president's engagement uh
with um the capitol police officer who
lost i think ed us this question perhaps
um
about the capitol police officer officer
who had lost his life
in the events of january 6th
as you know or many of you may know the
president spoke with members of his
family shortly after his passing to
express his condolences and sympathies
to their tragic loss i don't have
anything to update in terms
of his schedule tomorrow but i expect we
will have
um more of an update on that in the next
24 hours certainly
finally i think finally i know this is a
lot at the top
uh we can confirm that the president
will visit the state department now on
thursday that was originally planned
earlier this week
we had to move things around because of
snow where he will thank the men and
women of the national security workforce
for their service to our country
and deliver remarks about reclaiming
america's role in the world
sorry i did actually have one more item
um
and as you all have seen reports this
morning of
the fbi confirmation that two fbi agents
are deceased and three are wounded um in
a shooting in florida
the two agent wounded agents were
transported to hospital and are in
stable condition as some i think have
reported
president biden was briefed this morning
by homeland security advisor liz
sherwood randall
this is obviously a terrible tragedy i
expect you'll hear more from the
president
later this afternoon when he speaks to
all of you
i know that was a lot with that let's
kick us off
wonderful thank you jen two questions
congressional democrats
are moving forward with coven relief
with legislation
set to hit the house budget committee by
february 16th
what kind of timeline does that create
for you with regard to talks with
republicans
well um as many of you who have covered
capitol hill know
um there is a process the budget
reconciliation process
is a lengthy one and because i suspected
that people would want to talk about the
meeting last night today
i just wanted to take the opportunity to
talk a little bit about that process and
where we see their up being opportunity
so
first um as you know uh once a budget
well maybe as you
you know but a lot of people watching do
not know um that once a budget
resolution is passed
the house and senate negotiators will
work to develop a reconciliation bill
that can pass through the house and
senate
at several points in this process as we
look to the weeks ahead republicans can
engage
and see their ideas adopted at any point
in the process
a bipartisan bill can pass on the floor
so just creating the option for
reconciliation with a budget resolution
does not foreclose other legislative
options this is my when a bill becomes a
law moment of the briefing today
second republican uh ideas can be
adopted during the reconciliat
reconciliation negotiations and is
likely that several bipartisan ideas may
be or we are certainly hopeful of that
and third republicans have the ability
to offer amendments
both during the budget resolution and
instruction phase of the process and
then later
during the reconciliation phase and in
that way can ensure
their ideas are heard and i did all of
that because i think it's important it's
there's been some misunderstanding about
how this process works and i think there
was some view that
the vote the final vote was this week
you all know that's not the case
there is some time that's why the
president is in great gauging why he did
with republicans last night
democrats today and why he's he's um
conveyed that he would like to continue
doing that in the days ahead
secondly uh moscow court sends the lexi
navalny to
prison for two and a half years for
violating his probation for going
to germany to recuperate from being
poisoned does the white house plan any
additional
steps in response well josh
you may not have seen this because i
think it just came out but secretary of
state tony blinken put out a statement
and in response to the sentencing uh
i will uh just let me reiterate some of
the pieces from here
we are deeply concerned by russian
authorities efforts uh
decision i should say to sentence
opposition uh figure
alessi navani like every russian citizen
mr navalny is entitled to the rights
provided in the russian constitution
and russia has international obligations
to respect equality before
the law and the rights to freedom of
expression and peaceful assembly
we reiterate our call for the russian
government to
immediately unconditionally release mr
navalny
as well as the hundreds of other russian
citizens wrongfully detained in recent
weeks for exercising
their rights i will say so on in to your
specific question
there is an ongoing review uh we
announced i think it was early last week
of a number of the uh um you know
reported or concerning actions i should
say by the russian government
which includes the treatment of alexey
navalny it includes
the full assessment of the solar winds
hacks hack
it includes a review of the
reports around bounties on troops and
also includes uh reports of uh
an assessment of of uh engagement in the
2020 election
that's an ongoing review by the national
security team when they conclude that
that will launch uh you know whatever a
policy process to determine what steps
we will take from here
go ahead uh on the relief bill democrats
are obviously moving ahead with this
process you all are still hopeful that
you can get bipartisan support but
you've also made it clear that
you're not going to slim down this bill
significantly so
where right now is the greatest
potential for compromise to try and
achieve
that bipartisanship well you're you're
right
uh mary that i think and this was uh
evident in the discussion last night it
was
as we said in our readout and i think as
senator collins also said
it was civil it was constructive this is
how democracy should work
we should be engaging democrats and
republicans should be engaging
with each other but there certainly is a
gap between where we are
and where the proposal the republican
proposal that was discussed
uh last night was uh there are some
you know bottom lines i think the
president has which he has
conveyed in the meeting last night and
reiterated to us this morning which is
you know to put it simply or accessibly
for people
you know he believes a married couple
let's say they're in scranton just for
the sake of argument uh
one is working as a nurse uh the other
is a teacher making 120 000
a year should get a check that's in his
plan and the plan presented by
republicans they would not get a check
and his view is that at this point in
our country
when one in seven american families
don't have enough food to eat
we need to make sure people get the
relief they need and are not left behind
as was also part of our readout last
night there was a discussion there's
some technical follow-up
where there's opportunity to discuss
issues like small business issues like
coveted relief
not i'm not suggesting a reduction i'm
suggesting how to do it effectively
and those technical discussions at a
staff level will be part of what's
ongoing over
the next couple of days but his bottom
the president's bottom line is that
this is a package the risk here as he
has said many times is not going too
too big it is going too small that
continues to be his belief and that's
why he can
he supports uh the efforts by senator
schumer leader schumer
and speaker pelosi to move this package
forward i might ask a question on
impeachment
the impeachment managers have now laid
out their case uh trump's team is
leaving open the door
it seems to arguing election fraud
in the trial to repeating the false
claims that somehow
trump won the election those same false
claims that fueled the riot
is this administration concerned that
the former president's defense
could incite further violence
well certainly watching uh reactions in
the country
watching the potential for violence is
something that we will do closely
from the white house across the country
no matter what prompts it
and that's something we will certainly
keep an eye on
but you know i think in this case as you
know
there have been dozens and dozens of
court cases that have been debunked
uh the president of the united states is
sitting in the oval office
um engaging and governing the country
and
obviously uh we have moved forward even
more than we were prior to the
inauguration in
uh proceeding and delivering on what the
american people decided on in november
one good one on immigration you know
some reform advocates have criticized
these actions for being
reviews of certain programs like the
remaining mexico program rather than
cancellations why review and not reverse
some of these programs sure well part of
our effort
mary is to assess uh the damage that
has been done by the policies
that were put in place by the prior
administration we want to act swiftly we
want to act promptly
but we also need to make sure we are
doing that
through a strategic policy process
and the president's commitment to
immigration is indicative in the fact
that he
announced an immigration bill his first
day in office and that he has
signed and after this afternoon a number
of bills to overturn
the immoral actions of the prior
administration
uh but uh we want to ensure that our
team led by uh
the new hopefully newly confirmed soon
uh maybe right now
uh secretary of homeland security has
the ability uh
to uh review the process and policies
and make sure he's putting the right
ones in place you have a sense of timing
for these reviews when the task force uh
reunification for instance may actually
put out their first
fight we do um and it's important to us
that there are markers
um to give updates to the american
people on this and many other issues so
there will be
a report issued within 120 days and then
every 60 days thereafter
um on the progress being made
as i think you all know from covering
this issue
this is very difficult uh it's emotional
for a lot of people for understandable
reasons
um and we need to find out first where
all these
kids are and figure out where their
parents are and so we are starting at
uh you know square one here um but our
team wants to ensure that we are
providing an
update on uh what progress were being
made
how the how it's going to be approached
and what the task force will be able to
uh
to get done uh go ahead on the same
subject and this is going to be really
big news
across latin america especially in those
countries where people have come from
um what is the biden administration's
message to people who may see this in
the news for the next few days and think
oh they're changing the policy now might
be a good time to go north well
the the message continues to be uh what
it has what it has been and i and i
appreciate you asking the questions
because it is confusing as we take a lot
of these steps forward
one is that this is not the time we want
to put in place an immigration
process here that can that is humane
that is moral that considers uh
applications for refugees
applications uh uh for people to come to
into this country
at the border in a in a in a way that
treats people
as human beings that's going to take
some time it's not going to happen
overnight
obviously we have a bill that we are
hoping we'll be able to move through
congress
but we also feel um i don't think any
parent
can look at what's happened to those
kids over the last couple of years
and not feel that we should do
everything in our power to get those
kids back with their parents
so we are trying to repair the damage
and the horrific actions of the prior
administration by trying to do
everything we can
to reunite these kids with their
families but it remains
a dangerous trip it remains a time this
is not the time
to come to the united states we need the
time to put
in place uh an immigration process so
people can be treated humanely one of
the other things that immigration groups
have been
talking about some democrats as well is
the idea
of potentially some kind of executive
action that would shield
immigrant workers who are considered
essential workers
from the threat of deportation is that
being considered is that being worked on
uh this will not be the end of our
immigration actions
or our actions our efforts to work on
these issues um
i don't have anything on that policy
consideration for you though that was my
next question
this is still being worked on can you
give us a sense of what else may still
be coming
well then i would i would be getting
ahead of a policy process which i can't
do from here ed but
this is a priority to the president uh
to
uh and to do everything he can obviously
putting forward the bill but also taking
the executive actions he
he had in his power to take to overturn
the immoral steps of the last
administration so
that's why he's doing all of these uh
taking all of these steps within the
first two weeks of being inaugurated
this one might be similar but i want to
ask it anyway
sure uh one of the things that was not
addressed by these was
the so-called title 42 uh the cdc thing
expelling migrants and asylum seekers
were literally no due process during the
pandemic
the idea that they could be sent back
right away because of the pen
is that up for review and why was that
not perhaps addressed right away since
it's been
a concern for a lot of advocates of
immigrants who are trying
to certainly i i know it has been um i
would just say that
continuing to take policy steps to
address the plight of immigrant of
migrant families to
do so in a humane and moral way is a
priority of this administration
we obviously are going to continue to
work on the immigration bill that we
have proposed to congress
these executive actions are just part of
our strategy um
and if there's more uh to report to you
on that i'm i'm happy to
uh get to you directly uh go ahead let
me follow up on the immigration
question the executive orders have been
described so far don't actually
change or raise the refugee cap which
you know president trump
reduced substantially doesn't also order
the immediate release of children from
ice
detention the president has said that
that's something that should be done
immediately why didn't he do it today
uh i think we're gonna have more again
um
soon in the coming days and weeks on
more steps and actions that um
the president is interested in taking so
i'm just not gonna get ahead of that
right now
might still do it but just isn't doing
it immediately again i was saying that
uh there are additional steps the
president will take our policy teams
will take
um our experts will take to uh address
immigration in a humane and moral way
there are also a number of steps that
are under the purview of the department
of homeland security and
secretary mayorkas who of course as you
know his confirmation was
a bit delayed some of those are going to
be under his purview
um and so i point to them to also engage
with on some of those questions but
there is more the president will have to
share on refugees and other issues soon
they ask whether the president has made
a decision on keeping or
keeping the scope of space force wow
space force it's the plane of today
um it is an interesting question um
i am happy to check with our space force
point of contact i'm not sure who that
is i will find out and see if we have
any update on that
uh go ahead um couple uh
start with coco relief senator manchin
said when i was saving saying he was
going to vote for the budget
uh proposal but made clear that his
final vote
needs to be a proposal that's very
targeted he's opposed to the 15
minimum wage is the 15 minimum wage a
must have
for this white house in any final
package well
um phil i should have also brought you
up here to just talk about how bill
becomes the law
because i think you know you have a
17-part reconciliation instructions
question oh good i can't wait we'll all
tune in for it um
you know phil i think um there are a lot
of um
points of view as should not be a
surprise to anyone of different members
of congress
we respect all of them we're happy to
hear them hence the president met with
10 republican senators last night but
we're not going to
negotiate from here or frankly in public
about what is going to be in and out of
the package we want that to work through
the legislative practice
practice process sorry that is that is
ongoing now
and then on the meeting with the
republican senators you know you
said the word reiterate i think in the
statement last night had the word
reiterate
three separate times like it's very
clear we like that word it's a good word
it's a solid word
your guy's position is firm and so i
guess my question is you're talking
about staff talks on technical details
is that basically
the ball game right now in terms of the
bipartisan talks like they can put
things on the technical side there are
pieces if they want amendments
but this is what it is and it's moving
well i think the president's uh
commitment is to
urgently deliver relief to the american
people and that is what he has conveyed
in every meeting he's had or engagement
he's had with democrats and republicans
and as we just talked about there's a
process that's just in the early stages
that's beginning on capitol hill
to do exactly that but there are also
steps that can be taken or
changes that can be made through
negotiations that also
through the legislative process have to
happen between the house and senate
there are amendments that can be
proposed and voted on and we're going to
see that process through or allow that
process to go through
as that's happening the president will
be continue to be engaged he'll continue
to have more discussions with a variety
of members of congress from both parties
to see if there's
places to come to consensus and
agreement on how to approach some of the
issues and challenges the american
people are facing
last one you guys have made very clear
the 130 billion dollars for k
through 12 is crucial to reopening
schools the
i think there's something along the
lines of 60 to 65 billion
in past proposals that have been
obligated but is mostly unspent
right now on the public school front
what are you guys doing to ensure
that gets out the door given the
priority it is in your next package
sure well um my understanding from
talking to our economic team
is that uh the funding what that was in
the 900 billion dollar package
i think is if that's what you're
referring to will be spent in the next
couple of weeks and so what we're trying
to look ahead to
is what are the needs as we're looking
to public schools across the country
that many of them need funding many of
them need ppe many of them need testing
many of them need
um you know better ventilation in their
schools to ensure we have adequate
funding needed
to uh open the majority of schools
within 100 days which remains the
president's goal
go ahead um today there was new data on
the sputnik v
vaccine showing that it's quite
effective and i'm wondering if the
administration
is concerned at all that russia could
use this vaccine
to exert geopolitical power
with nations in need for perhaps in
latin america
that is not a concern i've discussed
with our national security team
uh obviously our focus is on our own fda
approval process here and ensuring that
we make
as much of the vaccine available to the
american public and
uh we just rejoined as you know uh the
world health organization because we
believe that
the more people who are vaccinated
around the world the safer we
all are um but i'm happy to speak with
them about it and see if that's a
concern they have one other question on
the
covid travel ban that is in place
um is that a temporary thing
while the cdc and and the obama
administration figure out a safe way for
international travel to occur or is that
seen as more long-term especially given
that the variants are already here
well these were steps taken as you know
by our team in order to increase the
safety of the american public and
certainly we don't want them to be
forever
because we want to get the pandemic
under control but they will be in place
as long as our health and medical
experts believe they're necessary or
essential
in order to keep the public safe so the
impact of variance which is a very good
question is something
you know they assess and i would
certainly encourage you to ask them that
question on our next covet call
go ahead um there have been calls for
some kind of boycott of the the
china's 2022 olympics given the
the administration's recent support of
the genocide designation there does this
president private sport
support those calls to perhaps find a
new host country
um and have they engaged with other
allies on that topic
uh well i've seen some reports of that
um
and uh i don't have any uh update for
you
or um preview for you or change of our
approach to
uh the beijing olympics now um president
has promised to make these visitor lodge
public and
bring that back that tradition obviously
you guys are not having a lot of
visitors do the pandemic
to the extent that these these calls are
taking on virtually is there any
talk about a virtual visitor live or
some kind of transparency
on how those virtual meetings are being
disclosed to the public
well our pledge is to be a venture to be
a
hope to be the most ethical uh ethically
stringent
uh government in in history and we've
put in place he's put in place a number
of
steps and policies to deliver on exactly
that
uh you're right that they're not uh are
not currently many visitors at some
point hopefully there will be and we
will
be returning to the release of those
visitor logs that was not the case
during the prior administration
at this point there's not a discussion
of making virtual meetings a part of
what's released
go ahead jeff hey john i actually have
more visitor logs questions
okay okay the first one is has anybody
in the administration
looked at the laws from the weeks before
or leading up to the
january 6th to see if anyone connected
with the right of being in the building
you are not the first person to ask this
question it's a very interesting one or
newsworthy one i guess i should say
i have not had a chance to talk to our
team on whether we even have access to
those logs i mean we obviously
know what information is put in from
visits people who come to visit
and we have a abil the ability to
release that
over the coming months i'm not aware of
an assessment of that but i will also
ask our team if we have access to them
or if there's a plan to look at them
when you get back to releasing i know
under obama that came out on like a
monthly basis a few months after
the date of effect if it's possible
would you release them for the prior
administration
because there are a lot of people coming
in and out of here where the public
would only learn through a
random media report or a camera about a
picture i'm not even sure if it's
technically possible that feels like the
first question
so let me talk to our technical gurus
and see what i can find out
technical thing if you don't want the
first impeachment there's a lot
dealing with a foreign leader called by
the president to ukraine is that system
still intact where there's
notes and records of foreign leader
calls and is anybody
on nfc or anybody else looking at those
from the prior administration
past foreign calls by the predecessor
i i am not aware of an assessment of
those jeff i think our focus is on our
foreign leader calls the president the
current president of the united states
is making to global leaders in an effort
to rebuild our place in the world
and uh work on some diplomacy
katie hi um i just have another question
on immigration on the family
reunification task force can you talk i
know you said you're at square one but
can you talk a little bit more about
the work ahead and finding some of these
kids i think the current
number it might be higher you can
correct me it's 600 or some
i'm also wondering if you can talk a
little bit about how officials are going
to evaluate cases to determine whether
the families
will be reunited in their home countries
or if they will be allowed to stay here
uh it's a great question katie and some
of that is what uh
secretary mayorkas newly newly confirmed
secretary mayorkas
and the uh task force we'll have to
assess is
and it will be a case by case um there
are estimates of between six and seven
hundred kids but
part of what we need to do in the early
stages or i should say what the task
force needs to do is determine what the
accurate number is and where these kids
are and then
determine case by case uh what the best
process and approaches for uh reuniting
them with their family members uh
so this is there's a great deal of work
ahead um there is a
team that is very committed to that work
and uh part of uh
what i'm sure will be in the report
around 120 days is is what progress
they've made on that effort
go ahead um does the president think
cutting off aid to myanmar's government
goes far enough or are you all looking
at additional steps and what
what might those be well i think the
state department
may have put a statement out if i'm
correct here on uh
on the assessment made in the legal
review uh
that is calling the events in burma a
coup
so and as you also know and we talked
about a little bit here yesterday but
there was a releasing of some there were
some sanctions relief
over the last several years because of
steps that
the government had taken toward
democracy there are there has been a
rollback of those and obviously looking
at sanctions
is a big tool uh that would certainly be
assessed
um and i think that would be the one i
would focus on at this point in time
we haven't heard the president we
haven't seen a readout of the president
talking to president xi and i was
wondering if there's something
scheduled or when that might be it's
been a couple weeks
less than two weeks actually it may seem
longer to you
uh you know the our
our our approach to um china
and our approach to our relationship in
china with china
um you know is um strategic
obviously and we are
working to ensure that we are
approaching that relationship from a
position
of strength uh and that includes
engagement with our allies and partners
a lot of those calls have happened over
the last 10 weeks
10 weeks 10 days maybe that was a little
40 in their 10 weeks
10 days they will continue and
also engagements with democrats and
republicans in congress about the path
forward
i don't have any call to predict for you
at this point in time obviously with
secretary of state tony blanken now
confirmed
there are additional layers to engage
with the chinese but
we'll let you know when a call is is
happening and certainly have a readout
for all of you as well sounds a lot like
the strategy is not to talk to him at
this time because you're talking about
speaking to allies and and making other
calls first
is uh have they requested a call i don't
have anything more for you i think i
don't appreciate the like putting words
in my mouth that wasn't what my effort
was what i was conveying is what our
strategy is here from the united states
which is to
work with our partners and allies and
determine what the right time is of
course the relationship with china
is going to be multi-layered we'll deal
with climate we'll deal with
uh we'll deal with the economy we'll
deal with uh security
uh and that is a of course a priority to
president biden he's spoken about it
during the transition he's spoken about
it obviously he's had
engagements with his national security
team about a range of issues including
china
we've been here less than two weeks and
when we have a call to read out
i'll make sure you know go ahead in the
back thanks jen i want to ask you a few
on the
rescue plan talks and i want to follow
up on a question that phil had asked you
um
you would acknowledge that the the gap
between
the administration and republicans is
why but the talks last night was
constructive so
after the discussion in the oval office
last night
is the number from from the white house
still 1.9 trillion dollars
it is um on the issue
of the minimum wage
you had said that um the president
believes that
a nurse and a teacher a couple who makes
120 000
should get a check so that's clearly a a
quote unquote red line i don't know if
you want to describe it as that but
something that the president wants
an old term we're not going to use it
again
but when you're asked about the minimum
wage you said you're not going to
negotiate
from here and you want to work through
that so it seems as if
the president might be open to dropping
the minimum wage from the bill is that
i know there's a lot of appetite for
what is going to be negotiated out of
the bill i totally get it this is a big
topic of interest but
uh what i was just conveying as an
example is that
ensuring those checks are in the hands
of americans is
a top priority for the president i
wasn't taking in and out things in the
bill
that will be a negotiation that will
happen through democrats and republicans
in congress
obviously the reconciliation process has
just started there are many
opportunities for republicans to offer
amendments there's a whole negotiation
that's going to take place
and will the president will continue to
be engaged with members of both parties
through that process on the issue of
senator manchin in his statement today
he talked about how
he would like to see something targeted
he said let me be clear and those are
the words i shared with president biden
our focus must be targeted on the kobit
19 crisis
and americans who have been most
impacted by the pandemic his quote
uh does the white house believe that 1.9
trillion is a targeted package
well the size of the package was
determined not for shock value but
to address the dual crises that we're
facing
and uh that includes ensuring that
millions of americans
can put food on the table one in seven
americans uh american families don't
are concerned about food security right
now it ensures that we have funding that
we can
uh reopen schools so that kids can go
back to school
mothers and fathers could not worry
about their kids and insurance that
that people can apply for unemployment
insurance these the the size of the
package was determined of course in
consultation with members on the hill
but also
based on the recommendations of uh
economists on health experts and
uh that's how we came up with that
number lastly there's gonna be a jobs
report on friday
on how that jobs report looks might that
change
how the white house views what needs to
be in the package or not
or you kind of believe that this is the
best framework now and that's what
you're going with
i mean if there was a jobs report that
there were 10 million jobs created that
would be great news
i don't suspect that will be what the
outcome of the jobs numbers will be
um so no it will not change as we saw
from the cbo numbers
um were there which predict projected i
should say that
there would be growth this year that's
obviously positive but we're digging out
of a massive hole and the challenge
right now is that
it's going to take years to return to
the pace of job grow of economic growth
that the country needs to be at so no i
wouldn't suspect
it would change things go ahead in the
back thank you jen um a couple of
follow-ups
uh first to tamara's question uh
governor
hogan said that there has been two
new uh two more cases of the south
african variant
in montgomery county and is in maryland
uh
and people were coming back from abroad
i
i mean is is that an opportunity to
are you worried is that opportunity to
eventually widen the
travel restrictions well i think what
our
team our health and medical teams do so
the cdc and others who are
actual doctors is make assessments about
what steps need to be taken whether it's
masking
that as you know is now required on
planes or
travel restrictions from certain
countries in order to keep the american
people safe and certainly
the maryland obviously well i don't know
that it hasn't
worked because we also have prevented a
number of people from
coming into the country and tried to
take steps to reduce the spread
uh of covid and also uh the spread of
some of these variants but they will
assess steps that need to be taken based
on variants obviously that's something
that they
uh review on a daily basis
um correct me if i'm wrong but the
president hasn't
spoken yet with prime minister netanyahu
he's an ally he's not surprising
i i don't know that it's surprising less
than two weeks into an administration he
hasn't called every foreign leader yet
he certainly would love to spend more
time talking to foreign leaders that's
you know his first love is foreign
policy but i expect he'll continue to
have
additional engagements in the weeks
ahead and obviously we have
a long and abiding relationship with
israel uh
important security relationship i'm sure
they'll discuss that in a range of
issues when they do connect
shenzhen um since uh bill
and president clinton and president
obama made
canada the destination of the first
round can we expect the same thing from
uh i was that was a very creative way of
asking the first foreign trip
question uh i don't have anything to
preview for you in terms of
um which where the president will travel
on his first foreign trip i'm as eager
as you all are i'm as eager as you all
are i love foreign travel
uh i will remind you uh that you know
his first call was of course
the prime minister of canada so that is
certainly affirmation of the importance
of the relationship
uh so go ahead yeah thanks jen uh one on
immigration and one on jobs
uh that's okay sure the so the
president's third executive order as i'm
reading it restoring faith in our legal
immigration system
and promoting integration of new
americans should
visa applicants in the k-1 the student
e-2
visa program should they take this as a
sign that they'll be granted travel
waivers to return the united states i
know you were asked about that
last week yeah i was and it is still
under review
uh obviously as we talked about a little
about last week i don't remember if you
were here that day but
uh but it was a question someone else
asked and married couples as you know
are able to travel there was a review of
of students and
of couples who were not married that
review hasn't concluded yet
and then on jobs given that mayor i
guess
now secretary gutijudge has been
confirmed
when can we expect to see a detailed
infrastructure plan given the potential
for
new job creation there well we're we're
going to officially invite secretary
buda judge to come to this briefing room
and talk to you all about it whenever he
has that
to discuss or even before then um he has
been obviously
uh working on getting confirmed but i
know he's eager to get to work and
we'll see when he has more specifics to
laugh the announcement today with
respect to the vaccine equity is a big
part of that we've been rolling out that
previously what extent is international
equity factoring it right now the orders
you have add up if they all come through
which is admittedly a big if
to quite a bit more than the us would
need what would you do with all that and
are you concerned
that you might be boxing out less
wealthy countries from getting earlier
access to the vaccine
well that's certainly not our objective
the president's objective is to have as
many vaccines as you said there's a lot
of factors that could happen here
that would prevent this from happening
exactly as we've planned it
freezers can break trucks can break snow
storms
as we've seen this week we're fully
aware of that may our problem be that we
have too many vaccines to put in the
arms of the american people
that is not the current problem we're
tracking so that's what our first focus
is going to be at this point in time
will you distribute them to allies first
on the needs basis
i certainly hope that's our challenge
and our problem and i'm sure we will
be happy to discuss that if that is our
issue but as you know we've also
rejoined the world health organization
we want to have a seat at the table
it's important that our global community
is healthy not just our community in the
united states but we're going to focus
first on
ensuring the american people are
vaccinated go ahead another
vaccine question you guys you mentioned
you ramped up sixteen percent
distribution last week yeah five percent
you know we said the million doses going
out to the pharmacies as well
jeff was talking about how this is a
ramp up of madeira and pfizer
what kind of visibility are you getting
into what's coming
like did you know the 15 was or 16
last week was coming did you know the
five like how long in advance do you
know did we know we could plan
to announce the new actually announce
things and kick them into gear yeah
we're working on trying to be able to
have that ability in that assessment
as governors i'm sure will tell you or
have told many of you that's also what
they're looking on right looking at so
we're trying to get to a place where we
know
what's coming so governors and local
officials know what's coming to them
and they can assess where to distribute
it in their states
um you know the process is at the early
stages but our goal is certainly to have
an
understanding of uh when we'll be able
to ramp up
distribution to states on something like
today
how many days ago did you know okay on
tuesday we can announce
that on february 11th we've got a
million doses going out to pharmacies
what's the turnaround on that well that
particular announcement has a couple of
components right it's not it's of course
engagement
with states and governors and engaging
with them is pivotal but also with
pharmacies and ensuring
that they're able to do it i mean if you
log on to cvs to do
an appointment to get a flu shot you
want to know that the the system is
going to work so
there are a lot of steps in the process
i'm not sure how many days in advance
we knew that it was full to go not many
but
you know it takes a great deal of
coordination to make sure governors are
feel comfortable with the announcements
being made that we're fully coordinating
with them that
uh they can explain to their public that
of course pharmacies are just a part of
what we're doing right
uh it's not you know a million doses is
a lot it is not going to vaccinate the
entire country we're going to ramp that
up so
that leaves some onus on them to be able
to communicate where other people where
people can also get their vaccine so
that coordination is key as a part of it
several components in this one
but we don't usually sit on these
announcements so i don't think that long
go ahead jen senator schumer just came
out and said that he had a
really good lunch with uh the president
and secretary yellen uh he also said
that
the president told republicans last
night that the 600 billion was way too
small
does that track what he with your
understanding of what he actually said
to them last night
yes i mean the president has been clear
that our risk is not
having a package that's too big it's
having a package that's too small and
there have been public proposals of
course
by by these senators and by others to
split the package to do a smaller
package
and his view is that their key
components
and funding that would be needed in
order to ensure that
millions of millions of people have
checks um
you know in their hands that we make
ensure people are getting those fourteen
hundred dollar checks
that we ensure that we are properly
funding schools to reopen
uh that people can uh that we're getting
we have the funding needed to get shots
in the arms
of the american people so uh that is uh
not a cheap endeavor and one that uh but
those key components are all a priority
to the president go ahead anita
i just wanted to follow up on the
meeting last night in the readout and
all that we've heard is about
the relief built did any other issue
come up it was quite a lengthy meeting
couple hours
i wondered if the president brought up
anything or if the senators brought up
executive orders or other policy issues
or was it
solely focused it was focused on the
american rescue plan and
they had a robust discussion about it i
don't have any more of a readout for you
than what we provided last night
i know that i think it was happening as
we came out i know it's happening right
now so i don't actually know but we will
we will put out
um a readout of it afterwards always
just to
discuss the same but nothing else
exactly that was the and obviously
people can raise what they want to raise
i'm sure democratic senators will share
with all of you what they raised but
uh the focus of it was to discuss the
american rescue plan uh the path forward
uh and the imperative of moving it ahead
go ahead in the back
i'll go ahead oh sorry go ahead okay um
is there any
plan or date set for the president to
address a joint session of congress
and are you guys already working on his
address and
is selling the american rescue package
part of that and in what way
uh not yet and not yet to the first two
questions
um and it really depends on the timing
of course we have there's urgency
as you've heard the president saying all
of us say in moving this package forward
i think as he also said in his prime
time address when he rolled and he
announced the american
rescue plan he also has plans to
announce a buildback better agenda
and our plans would be to do that once
we are at a point where it's
um that can be the next priority um so
it really did we don't have a date yet
and depends on when that date is and
what the focus will be and
not working on it quite yet uh go ahead
yeah so on the on the uae
aluminum tariff announcement i know the
president has insinuated that he wants
to do a full review
of former president trump's tariffs
before acting on any of those and
he uh you know the president the former
president signed that out on december
31st
should we take this announcement as an
indication that that review is
completed or is this just a one-off
instance
uh specifically pertaining to uae so
uh as you said and for people who are
not totally as familiar with this issue
as you are and there's a lot going on in
the news
um you know shortly before the
inauguration of president biden the
united states lifted a 10
existing tariff under section 232 of the
trade expansion act on aluminum imports
for the uae his campaign promise
included a commitment to carefully
evaluating all steps taken by the
previous administration on trade as you
also said
including the private deals and
assurances that may have been made
um as part of his campaign commitment we
are commit
conducting an immediate review so the
review is uh
underway of the previous
administration's trade policy to
determine
what steps need to be taken so
that includes you know decisions on
tariffs
and you know the the previous
administration's
decision to lift the existing tariff on
on the uae under section 230 at the last
hour was made clearly in our view on the
basis of foreign policy issues unrelated
to trade so it's all part of the ongoing
review
great thanks everyone see you tomorrow
you